comenzó preguntándole cuáles han sido
las implicaciones o las reacciones de
los republicanos y los demócratas
después del anuncio del fallecimiento de
arbilla y explican los cuales la batalla
política que se avecina bueno tanto
republicanos como demócratas están
lamentando la muerte de esta persona
pues de esta jueza que era considerado
una pionera y una defensora de los
derechos de la mujer pero esto ha tomado
rápidamente un aspecto político después
de que el líder de la mayoría
republicana del senado mitch mcconnell
confirmara que va a haber un voto
justamente para confirmar a la persona
que donald trump designe para reemplazar
a arbey y entonces por otro lado los
demócratas principalmente el candidato
joe biden están pidiendo que primero
haya una elección y que sea el
presidente el encargado de designar a
ese reemplazo entonces esto hace eco de
un caso del año 2016 cuando el juez de
maryland que fue denominado por barack
obama fue bloqueado por los republicanos
en el senado justamente porque decían
que el país estaba en un año electoral y
que había que esperar la voluntad del
pueblo
ahora la batalla va a consistir
básicamente en los unos demócratas
tratando de dilatar este proceso de
confirmación y los republicanos tratando
de llevarlo por la vía expresa bueno y
más allá de si lo dilatan o no el
promedio en el que se toman estas
elecciones son 72 días y recordemos que
son menos de dos meses antes de las
elecciones presidenciales porque es
andrés tan importante el reemplazo de la
jueza y qué implicaciones va a tener
esto para la carrera presidencial
bueno pues tenemos que recordar que la
corte suprema en este antes de la muerte
de rupert ginsburg se consideraba que
había cuatro jueces de corte liberal
cuatro de corte conservador más el
presidente de la corte que es john
roberts que también es conservador
entonces se consideraba que había una
inclinación de cinco a cuatro a favor de
los conservadores si donald trump llega
a nominar y a poner a un tercer juez en
esa corte significa que ese
desequilibrio pasa a ser de 6 a 3 y eso
despierta el interés de todos los
votantes tanto republicanos como
demócratas porque muchos consideran que
hay demasiado en juego se cree que está
en juego el tema del derecho al aborto
el cambio climático los límites del
poder del ejecutivo la segunda
entonces básicamente estamos en un
contexto en el que además de unas
protestas muy fuertes por el tema racial
en eeuu de una pandemia que se ha
llevado a casi doscientas mil personas y
de una crisis de empleo ahora la corte
suprema- pasa a ocupar un rol central en
esta carrera donde donald trump por un
lado dice que tiene una lista de jueces
muy conservadores y para el otro lado yo
badén no tiene una lista pero dice que
si se le da la oportunidad pondría la
primera mujer afroamericana en el cargo
entonces nos enfrentamos a un tema de
extrema polarización gracias